in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Jeremy and Corey are with us Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas good to have
you guys where do you live Marietta
Georgia oh the Atlanta area okay well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream we are cool now who'd you bring
with you the kiddos here and they have
good names and ages we've got Anya who's
12 Maddie who's 9 and Breck is 17 all
right very cool and how much dad of you
guys paid off we paid off 192 thousand
whoa how long did this take you 19
months 19 months and making what kind of
money during this time well Dave I'm
self-employed and 2014 I made 360
taxable income and this year will be
four hundred and seventy or so awesome
good for you what kind of business have
you got CPA good for you why did it go
man killing it and the 192 what kind of
debt was this well we were pretty normal
we had a little bit of everything we had
lots of credit cards two cars a student
loan and a really awesome personal loan
he's a freakin CPA CPAs are all about
debt ya know like leveraged
congratulations you guys so so you paid
off everything yes everything that's a
lot of debt in just 19 months it was a
ton of debt that's amazing so tell me
the story what happened nineteen months
ago well it really started more than 19
months ago about three years ago I found
financial piece the book on our
bookshelf upstairs and didn't even know
that we had it I read it thought it was
a really great idea to get out of debt
and um we just I mentioned it to Jeremy
and he was kind of like whatever I don't
know that seems pretty lame and so I
sort of started it kind of dragging him
he really wasn't into it and then 19
months ago he had an opportunity to buy
into his partnership which was going to
cost us about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars which of course we
didn't have and so he said well we got
to take out a loan for a hundred
thousand dollars so that I can buy into
this partnership and we
the biggest fight we've ever had before
in our entire lives to the point where
he thought we were probably going to get
divorced and I almost threw him in a
fire pit and then so he went and took
out a big fight you get thrown in the
park yeah yeah um he went and took out
the loan and I signed us up for
financial piece so I said we're going to
financial piece he said this sucks but
fine we walk into the first class and
they tell us don't take out any debt
while you're in this class and I think
the day before he had signed the papers
all alone yeah so we went through the
class and for the first seven months he
really wasn't into it he you know he
went and he listened but it wasn't
really his thing and so it was really
hard to kind of get him on board and to
get him working with me and about seven
months into it I told him he had to go
to entree leadership that I thought it
would be just a great fit for him and he
did and he came home and was like
totally fired up gung-ho that's exactly
what he needed was a business
perspective and came home and so then in
the last 12 months we like really really
kicked it off kicked into high gear and
got it all done so Jeremy which contrary
leadership did you go to until one day
no it's the three day a three day yeah
okay up here yeah up here last September
I was awoken in those gap yep okay and
Chris is the one that actually got me
fired up okay all right I did good very
cool very cool so uh what was different
about the entree leadership that flipped
a switch in your brain that was
different than FPU that's interesting
well yeah a couple of things here and
other business owners talk about their
struggles and some of them were invested
in it some of them weren't and then you
know the one that really got me was when
Chris talked about walking into a car
dealership with a with a briefcase full
of cash and I was like man I want to do
that that's cool and we can do that and
so I call Cory right after that session
I'm like all right I'm in we're doing it
and and we did we really kicked it high
gear then it was both of us then not
just her Cory how did you feel when he
made that phone call to you oh my gosh
it was like the best phone call I could
have ever gotten because I had been
trying to get him dad you didn't throw
him in the fire oh yeah
really happy then that's awesome you
guys yeah so you come home from that and
and it goes into overdrive that
absolutely and and with because you got
a great income I mean you got a big
shovel and and you had a big hole you're
in but so the 192 includes this
partnership loan oh wow okay all right
so more than half of it was that all
right Wow
and you clear it all up in 19 months
yeah how long have you two been married
15 years 15 years have you ever been
debt-free while you were married until
now how does it feel it's so it's so
great and it's so funny because like we
live in a hundred year old home and so
you know things can go wrong all the
time
well nothing went wrong like through
this whole process we were just like oh
this is great our house isn't breaking
right and then we get out of debt and
have the month of October that we got
out of debt in September got out in the
month of October we put a bunch of money
towards our emergency fund and and then
November it was like this guy fell out
and every single thing that could have
gone wrong with our house did it was
like God was just holding on to
everything that was gonna go wrong until
we could actually pay cash for it
already for yeah and so we had to put a
new roof on her house way to do all
kinds of stuff and we had the money and
it was just so it was so awesome to be
able to just do do what we needed to do
absolutely awesome guys so what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is I mean I from my perspective
it's to stick to the plan you lay out a
very good plan the baby steps I mean
they're painful for a person like me
this has big income and then I can't
spend any I got really upset about that
a lot but I mean in hindsight sticking
to the plan it worked I wish we had
stuck to it earlier there's a lot of
principles in it that that are good
I appreciate what you do for all of us I
appreciate that very much
oh what about you Corey what do you see
the secret to getting out of debt is I
really think it's two things it's one
using cash and just being committed to
cash it's really fun and it was fun with
them showing them here's the envelope
and we're going to the grocery store but
other I think the biggest part really is
contentment and and understanding that
even when you are a high income earner
that you know $20 still doesn't matter
you know going in and spending twenty
dollars at Target which adds up to a
hundred really fast you know it matters
and we're just like everybody else and
we have to watch it just like everyone
else and and be content with clothes and
things like that and just normal living
things and just be happy
I really appreciate y'all being real
about your disconnect and the fights
that led into this and and as you go
along because that's what really happens
in the real world I mean everybody comes
on here so not everybody but sometimes
people come on here and they're act like
it's all like they're cannon Barbie and
we never find that's what people just
the people do they want to throw some
light a fire pit that's the real world
it really is and so thank you for doing
that and for you know if we're coming
clean on that and just talking about
because it makes makes your story
believable
and because you really did do that you
know Jeremy I'm a hardhead like you are
I mean I always assumed that somebody's
selling something they got something to
sell and they gotta get something in the
game you know yeah I mean I have my
shields up all the time for stuff like
that and so I probably would have taken
the exact same path you took talk to
that guy that's like you or like me
that's out there for a minute that's got
their shields up you know I gotta say
it's you can't you know see it do you
live it necessarily but you know being
debt-free and being the the wage earner
in the home or the primary wage earner
and the stress that has come off of me
in the last three months of providing
for my family and knowing that I don't
have you know six seven eight thousand
dollars a month in debt payments but
that has changed I think the way I am at
work the way on home the way Cory and I
are together because I feel free and I'm
not trapped anymore
there's no bondage anymore and that's
the thing you have to you know anybody
that's in that much debt has to look at
it and think about the freedom at the
end and it's there dang dang well sad
brother love it alright Jeremy Corey
Breck on ye on ye I messed up your name
I'm sorry that's Maddie
everybody's here from Mary
giorgia a hundred and ninety two
thousand dollars paid off in nineteen
months making 360 to 420 big income but
paid off a ton of debt in a short period
of time count it down let's hear your
debt free scream three two one we're
dead free yeah baby that's how it's done
you know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express gonna call my house and ask my
wife why she would stay with a man that
won't pay his bills